les robes le maire élu mais ce france
1976 mademoiselle body plus à risque
michel veillon
je vais montrer cette partie et des
larmes de sang ce qui en fait la réunion
on n'avait pas
j'en ai me
tristan peut-être dû chanter une chanson
là
ça disait quoi
qu'est-ce que vous avez quelque chose de
meilleur
si on me demande de main vous devrez
hier j'étais élue miss flandre
à
nous sommes arrivés maintenant à donner
une notoriété allait s'en dispensent la
meilleure preuve c'est que en 1947 il y
avait quinze candidates et que
maintenant en 1975 1976 il y en a 54
donc disons que c'est en progression et
tout ce qui a un peu de succès est
forcément limitée on dit que ce sera une
affaire de business et c'est intéressant
alors je suis très content que vous me
posiez cette question parce que vous il
sera très facile de me renseigner
je peux vous dire et je suis très fier
de pouvoir vous dire que ça c'est que
l'ex miss france se déroule sans un sou
de subventions nous faisons ça avec le
concours des fromages des produits du
terroir qui s'associent vous allez
perdre de l'intérieur de la miss bien
entendu d'ailleurs miss france est
pratiquement un an avec nous elle
participe à toutes les manifestations au
cours desquelles seront aidés les
prochaines communales à 1110 france est
en quelque sorte d'angoissé rios de miss
france pendant un moment je ne sais pas
imprésario je suis dix ans dix ans pour
sabine une deuxième famille parce que ça
se passe dans un esprit très familial
mon mari mes fils et je ne veux
absolument pas du moins pour sa rios est
en excès pas une affaire commerciale